Lyne Sonia Vostok must be the most
attractive place in Germany nothing but
hot bodies as far as I can see and I'm
lucky enough to have a front-row seat
this must be the best job in the world
I'm surrounded by attractive men all in
all seventy nice guys are fighting for
the title but that can only be one
winner and here he is mr. Germany 2017
23 year-old Dominic Blanca from southern
Germany beat all the competition it's a
dream come true it's incredible we've
been working towards this day for two or
three months and now here we are
everyone who's still up here wanted to
enjoy the moment and hear his number
called but in the end I'm the one
standing here as mr. Germany 2017 but
what part of a man's Anatomy do the
women here find most eye-catching he's
bummed to be honest upper arms are
important to his six-pack his shoulders
of course you need a strong shoulder to
lean on our findings are backed up in a
study in a German magazine it found that
women said great store in a man's
physique his backside and well-defined
upper body in particular well let's see
what the most cute looking men in the
country have to offer at those points
[Music]
so I found three men to compete in three
disciplines and these are our candidates
I'm Stephan rosenberger and 27 from
Hanover and I'm mr. Blaine my name is
Marko Tarullo I'm 28 from Coblentz and
I'm mr. Highland Falls
I'm Fabien furnish mr. central Germany
I'm 24 and come from Bharatha now our
first discipline knee bends who can
perform the most in a minute discipline
number two push-ups
[Applause]
[Music]
and finally sit-ups who can do the most
in 60 seconds to be honest I love my job
[Music]
man oh man it's a three-way tie so here
is our mini band mister pushup and mr.
sit up what's your formula smiling is
really important and it's also good for
the stomach muscles so you kill two
birds with one stone but to score points
with the jury here a man needs to do
more than just look nice he's got to be
beautiful on the inside - then his
character comes into play and whether
he's on the ball or not and then I'm
taken with him from my viewpoint
it's definitely intelligence as a woman
there's nothing worse than realizing a
man just isn't at your level and that
you can't conduct a conversation with
him the most important thing about an
attractive man if I can call him that is
charm and charisma
Dominic Warner appears to have met all
the criteria and being named mr. Germany
2017 so does he have a secret to a
success
my secret recipes that I don't fake
anything I'm true to myself and if that
goes over well with people then I'm
happy
Dominic is celebrating his victory he'll
hold the title mr. Germany for a year
then it'll once again be time to post a
question who's sephorus in all the land
always like from shoulder to lean on so
our mind if that strong shoulder belong
to a man as good-looking as mr. Germany
[Music]
you